The Joe Rogan experience matter.
Now, I don't know either vaccines, you know? Yeah.
I'm excited. Um, I like the vaccines. I,
I am vaccinated. Um,
the problem that a lot of people have is that this was
fast tracked and they get nervous about they do
possible potential side effects and we don't know what those are going to be.
And then there's a lot of people that are very uncomfortable with the idea of
getting very sick after they take the vaccine,
which seems to happen with 80% of the people that take it.
And so they're concerned about that, right?
80% Of people who are taking this vaccine, that's not what I heard. Well,
that's what bill Gates has said. Bill Gates. Yeah. I don't know. I mean,
I don't know. I don't know if we can look it up, pull it off of, I know. Yeah.
It's weird when people say that people like, wait, what? Um,
it's on my Instagram,
there's a interview with bill Gates where he's talking about,
I believe this is the Madonna vaccine.
The Pfizer vaccine has a very similar effect because it's, um, the way this,
uh, M RNA vaccine works,
they've taken the common cold vaccine and added this to it.
So your body develops these proteins to fight off, but you get sick.
I mean, well, I can say, I don't know, you know, I mean,
I I've read the sort of report the readout from Pfizer and Madonna BioNTech.
Um, and they said there were very few serious side effects. I mean,
I don't know if it's a serious or not. I mean, I got the flu shot, you know, um,
whenever it was a couple of months ago and you know,
my arm hurt for a couple of days. And then that was the shot site.
I wouldn't do it just for,
that's just the injections that your body didn't feel bad. Right.
But it was fine, you know, I felt, okay, this is different than that. Um,
this is different.
And there's, uh, there's consequences to taking this.
And I'm not saying that I won't take it. I will, if it's safe,
I will encourage other people to take it too.
But there's a reality of taking this particular vaccine that it's going
to make a lot of people feel like. And it'll last a couple of days. And look,
you can play, play that video. Oh, okay.
But it's in the, it's in the feed. It's in the, I G T V.
But if you just go to my Instagram feed from the last time, uh,
the Dylan Jones episode, um, it's,
uh, it's, that's just what it is.
Okay.
Hold up. You went way too far. Go, go way up, way up.
Hold on, keep going.
Wait a minute. Did they remove it? I didn't see it.
Oh my God. Did they remove it from my Instagram? Is that real?
Holy, dude. That is crazy. Hold on. Let me check.
Cause that's kind of crazy if they removed it from my Instagram,
that's kind of crazy because this was a,
I believe it was an NBC interview.
Oh, they removed it. Wow.
Okay. Well, here, here, I got, I got an article from.
From science. It says, uh,
there's fever and aches that are intense in some cases,
but not dangerous. It found. Okay. Okay. It hasn't been removed that. Okay,
here we go. Here's why don't I find it? I don't know. It was a month ago.
She says October 28th. Right? Okay. But
this video is edited though. Remember how so? No, no,
no, no, no, no, no. That's a totally different video.
That's a totally different video.
That video was the video where people were talking about, uh,
that bill Gates is concerned with the profit margin from vaccines,
but that is, we should talk about that too, because that's actually important.
That's actually important because that's really distorted and that's not what he
was saying at all. He was not talking about profits.
Turning. We looked after the second dose,
at least 80% of participants experienced a systemic side
effect ranging from severe chills to fevers.
So are these vaccines safe?
Well, the, uh,
the FDA not being pressured will look
hard at that. The FDA is the gold standard of regulators, uh,
and their current guidance on this. If they stick with that is, is very,
very appropriate. Uh, and you know, it,
that the, the, the side effects were not super severe. That is,
it didn't cause permanent health problems for, uh,
the things that they, you know, Madrona did have to go with a fairly high dose.
And so, uh, you know, to get the antibodies,
some of the other vaccines, uh,
are going able to go with lower doses to get, uh,
responses that are, are pretty high, including the J and J and the Pfizer.
And so there's a lot of characteristics of these vaccines. Um,
it's great that we have multiple of them, uh,
that are going out there and you got a site.
You know, the data better than I do,
but the bill bill that the data that everybody with a high dose had a side
effect.
Yeah. But some of that is, is not dramatic where, you know, it's just, you know,
super painful, but yes, there,
we need to make sure there's not severe side effects the FDA. Uh,
I, I, I think we'll do a good job of that. Uh, despite the pressure.
How many doses of the vaccine will we need?
Well,
none of the vaccines at this point appear like they'll work with a single dose.
That was the, the hope at the very beginning. Uh,
maybe one of them, particularly in the second generation won't surprise us.
We hope just too, although in the elderly sometimes, uh, it,
it takes more. And,
and so making sure we have lots of elderly people in trial will.
Give us that data. No. So that is still on the second. Yeah.
If that is all it is, it's just, you,
you have severe chills and you feel like for a couple of days,
that is way better than getting the Corona virus and risking the potential death
and side effects and, you know,
long haul people experiencing blood clots. And if it's better than that.
Yeah. But it's just not, it's not a free ride.
So I should, I just, I just want to get the numbers of what I see here from,
from science is that, uh, the, the sort of fatigue, you know,
that you were talking about feel shift for two days,
they did about 10% of people had had the side effects.
Hold on a second, but why is bill Gates saying 80%?
I, she was saying, it's some side effect comes in 80%. Right.
But like what you were talking about, isn't a subset of the people. Get it.
Well, well, hold on internet,
I don't know if that's true because there's many articles about the side effects
of this vaccine.
I've never seen one of them that relegated it to 10% of the population that took
the vaccine. I mean, obviously typically the second dose,
the other thing about this is you have to take to the second dose seems to be
the doozy for people. Right.
I guess that's the, that's a tough one. Um, there's something about,
so this is something that's interesting is I have like one set of conversations
with people and they're saying, who's going to be able to get the vaccine, like,
how are we going to roll this out? You know, healthcare workers,
essential workers, all this other kind of stuff.
And then there's another conversation where people are like,
maybe you're not going to want to get it. Right. And me, I'm like,
I'm really eager, you know, give it to me tomorrow.
I don't even care that the FDA has not done. Why is that? Um,
you're not worried about side effects. Hey, I'm not worried about side effects.
You're not worried about side effects cause fever for a couple of days.
I mean, that's what if that's all we know of now? Yeah.
But look long haul COVID survivors.
One of the things they're finding is these people have blood clots, like many,
many months later, no serious, serious.
Like I, I would really like to not get COVID. Yeah.
So what if this similar situation with the vaccine,
what does the vaccine,
and this is not outside of the realm of possibility that the vaccine gives some
sort of a side effect that that's unintended.
I have a lot of confidence in the basic process here, uh,
with the vaccine develop.
This isn't the basic process. This is a completely new process,
much faster than any process that will usually rapid development event.
I mean, it's an unusually rapid development because they have this MNR, M R N a.
I don't know what that means. I mean, it's, it's messenger RNA,
but I don't know what it means. Um.
Well, it just means that it's trick. It's not giving you, uh, uh,
like a dormant version.
There's no virus, right? There's a particle that's specially designed it,
triggers antibody is we create them. Um,
and so I think the basic antibody immune response situation is fairly well
understood scientifically.
It's why we're pretty confident that the people who've recovered, you know,
are immune that, you know,
younger and healthier people in cases are okay. If they get sick,
they get better. Um, so to me, like, it's a good thing.
I'm all for it. I'll take it, I'll get the fever, but I'm also not.
I want to walk the line. Like I want to encourage people to take vaccines,
like as a responsible person, but also knowing that the supplies will be short.
If somebody doesn't want it, like somebody else will take that dose.
But you know, one of the best things, uh,
in terms of outcomes is vitamin D
vitamin D deficiencies are a huge part of negative COVID outcomes.
And that one.
In one study, some people, some studies.
About that. Yeah. One study,
84% of the people that were in the ICU had deficient levels of vitamin C and
only 4% had sufficient levels of vitamin D.
Vitamin D is a huge problem. And it's not just a vitamin, it's a hormone.
You know, when, when Jay Mackey was on the other day,
he was trying to say that it's a precursor to hormones.
So I'd have to look it up. That's not true. It's a hormone.
Vitamin D is actually a hormone. And it's weird cause we call it a vitamin,
but it regulates so many things in the body.
And it has a significant impact on the immune system.
But you never hear anybody telling you to supplement with vitamin D.
You're not seeing this from any of the leaders,
any of these politicians that are shutting things down,
even Fowchee has said it recently that vitamin D does seem to have a pretty
significant impact,
but health experts like people that study like the mechanisms of
disease and vitamin supplementation, like particularly Dr.
Rhonda Patrick had a thing on her Twitter,
we should publish a study that showed positive outcomes and COVID vitamin D is
a huge factor. Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free.
Only on Spotify,
watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.